- I had the honor of visiting
the White House last week
to interview the First Lady.
It's still sinking in.
After our chat, Dr. Biden
asked me just casual-like,
was like, "Oh, you want to
go see the Oval Office?"
And I was like, who says no to that?
No one says no to that.
And it's kind of overwhelming.
See, there we are.
Isn't that so cool?
(audience laughing)
So cool.
It's never not gonna be cool.
I'm getting it like,
blown-up in my office.
But it's just nice to be in a place
where really important things happen.
And the President was so welcoming.
And what's crazy is Dr.
Biden told the President
that my mama was a teacher,
and he immediately,
like, didn't skip a beat,
and he goes, "Well, let's just
call her, let's call her."
And I was like, "What?"
(audience laughing)
And then he asked for her number,
and then I look like
such a horrible daughter
because no one knows
anyone's number. (laughing)
(audience laughing)
You just know mom in your
contacts, so. (laughing)
(audience laughing)
So now the aides are running around
trying to track down my
phone with my assistant,
and I'm stressing, 'cause I'm like,
you really don't have
to do it, it's so nice.
And I'm literally standing
in the Oval Office,
the Oval Office, mm-hmm,
just having a conversation
with President Biden and Dr. Jill Biden
while they're trying
to get ahold of my mom.
And then I look up, and
Tricia shows up with my phone,
and my musical director is with her.
And, were y'all-
Y'all looked like you were freaking out.
- Well, to be honest, I was just starving,
and I asked Tricia if
there was a sandwich,
and she said they had 'em
in your dressing room.
So when they came to get Tricia,
I grabbed your big makeup bag real quick
thinking, I'm getting a sandwich.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience laughing)
I never got the sandwich, but
I got to meet the President,
and I will carry your makeup bag any day.
(audience applauding)
- That was amazing.
I walk up and Jason's holding
a makeup bag, and I was like-
And it's like, the President's
there, and we're leaving.
And I said, "Oh, President
Biden, this is Tricia."
And then all of a sudden I see Jason.
I was like, why is Jason
holding a makeup bag?
(Jason laughing)
(audience laughing)
I was like, what's happening?
And he just wanted a sandwich.
We didn't get that.
But the President called
my mom the next day.
Literally.
And my mom answered the phone.
She was like, "Hello?"
And he was like, "Hi, I'm Joe Biden."
(laughing) And I was
like, what did you say?
(audience laughing)
Anyway, so we have her dialed in,
my mom is actually dialed in
right now, so what's up, Mom?
(audience applauding)
- Sweetheart.
- [Kelly] Hi.